let's say you know everything goes well
you guys get greenlit for a sequel what
would you want from a Deadpool sequel I
expect if we're gonna do a sequel let's
see I waited 10 years to do this first
one I've been begging Fox to make a
Deadpool movie for ten years it's been
like this has been a very very long road
for me so I felt like it was fitting if
we wait 10 years to do a sequel right so
Deadpool 2 coming soon in 2030 yeah I
have seen I might have I may have seen
some potential outlines for a sequel and
I made Oh Tim Miller has actually talked
about yet he wants like cable and the
sequel maybe some x-force action sure
sure sure and I don't want to be
President
well Deadpool's kind of a villain you
know he's kind of a morally flexible
yeah all right yeah so it's tough to
find it usually like the villain for a
debt in a Deadpool movie is the good guy
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Deadpool x-force video the people
behind the first movie have been talking
about the sequel as well as crossover
with x-men and x-force so here's a quick
breakdown good news bad news situation
the bad news is is they say there's not
gonna be any direct crossover with the
main x-men film series any time soon
it's just gonna be the way it was with
the first deadpool movie making fun of
x-men which I'm totally fine with the
tone of Deadpool is so different from
x-men right now the main x-men series
takes itself so seriously right now
they're doing Apocalypse they're blowing
up the world again
so not really expecting anyone to break
the fourth wall anytime soon even over
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe they
haven't really broken the fourth wall
yet the tonal is a little more whimsical
but the films still take themselves
pretty seriously
so the Deadpool universe is gonna be its
own thing the x-men universe is gonna be
its own thing the Deadpool writers
actually cited the Iron Man films there
like there were two Iron Man films
before we ever saw Avengers so think of
Deadpool appearing with the x-men I'm
talking about the main x-men team on
camera is being just like Iron Man with
the Avengers isn't it kind of funny how
times have changed normally you think
that Wolverine was the Iron Man
character of the x-men universe like
that one character who's super popular
and you can just put them in anyone
else's movie and it'll totally help out
now that character is Deadpool because
Hugh Jackman's kind of on his way out
even Ryan Reynolds was skeptical about
the idea of Hugh Jackman you know
putting the claws back on again after
his next Wolverine movie after that old
man Logan movie he's like he has
probably not gonna happen so Ryan
Reynolds Deadpool is the new Robert
Downey jr. Iron Man of Fox's x-men
universe and I think that's a good thing
Deadpool is such an extreme character
it's a lot easier for him to break
through the noise like the superhero
noise than any of the other more
stereotypical superheroes right now
Deadpool bigger character than
Apocalypse and Apocalypse is one of
those omega-level mutant sin the Fox
universe I've already talked about the
Deadpool sequel using cable there's a
number of ways they could pit them
against each other because for most of
their early relationship in the comics
they were always at each other's throats
Deadpool was always the villain Cable
was always the hero that had to stop him
but another funny quote from Ryan
Reynolds he said that because Deadpool
is the protagonist in all of his movies
that would make cable the villain
anybody that is a hero in a
movie is automatically the villain
anybody that's trying to stop Deadpool
from having his fun completing his
mission and what about x-force that
movies still in development but it's a
whole different thing from the Deadpool
sequel Fox was really hoping to spin out
a couple of their franchises because
x-men does fine it makes tons of money
but the more they can build out this
story universe that's what they call
these big film universes the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is a story universe
so all the film studios are trying to do
it because it makes tons of money and it
takes a lot of pressure off that one big
franchise like you don't always have to
crank out x-men films every single year
if you have a bunch of other franchises
inside that story universe that are
really popular too so now they have
Deadpool that makes two so they're
really happy about this x-force would
make three if it ends up being
successful in the Deadpool writers have
said that they are involved with the
x-force movie meaning that there's gonna
be some dead pointed I mean it just
makes sense
but they might have to change the way
Deadpool shows up in that x-force movie
just because the exact storyline for the
beginning that the very first x-force
comic was pretty straight it was cable
in the New Mutants trying to stop strife
working with Department K and they would
run into Deadpool every once in a while
but Deadpool wasn't a part of the team
or anything like that
x-force number one dropped in 1991
Deadpool didn't become a part of x-force
an actual part of the team until 2010 so
you're talking like 19 years worth of
stories where Deadpool was mostly the
villain in any x4 story but for the most
part usually when x-force went up
against Deadpool Deadpool had been hired
by someone else to steal something to
kill someone and x-force was brought in
to try and stop him so that's kind of
the way I'm expecting Deadpool to show
up in the x-force movie he'll still be
his own thing but x-force will be
brought on to stop Deadpool so Deadpool
doesn't so fundamentally changes the
character Kable can still be a hero and
if they really want to be crazy they
could totally do that story from uncanny
x-force it's gonna be a couple years
before we see the x-force movie they
don't even have a release date for it
yet but the storyline from uncanny
x-force is all about the resurrection of
apocalypse his followers are trying to
recreate him and at least to the
creation of the apocalypse clone Evan
kid apocalypse now they're just doing
x-men apocalypse right now I don't think
that they're gonna kill him at the end
of the movie he seems too big you never
truly kill big bad characters in comic
book movies they just go away for a long
time so I'm not expect
to duke it apocalypse but you guys can
let me know in the comments do you think
there's any chance that they would try
to do an uncanny x-force storyline where
x-force comes together and tries to stop
apocalypse from being resurrected or
being brought back in some big way it
seems like they try to keep the story a
little bit simpler than that
like the Deadpool movie for instance
they removed a bunch of characters so
that they could save money and doink it
apocalypse would require a lot of
special effects so I think any x4 story
they did will be based on the original
conceit of the team them just being a
team trying to stop Deadpool from doing
something crazy if you never read the
Deadpool vs. x-force comic book that was
also just like a limited run it was just
this funny story where Deadpool is hired
by someone to go back in time and change
the past
Deadpool goes rogue and saves Hitler
keeps Hitler alive well into the 90s so
Nazis have completely taken over America
and Cable has to go stop him he's just
like son of a he has to go back in
time and stop Deadpool from changing
history because they've already said the
cable is gonna stay in present-day
whenever he and Deadpool team up for
their next movie we'll probably only be
seeing jokes about time travel but I
totally think they would try to do the
strife character eventually so
executioner's song would be a really
awesome storyline to set up in that
first x-force movie that's really what I
think they'll try to do because if
x-force is successful they can build it
out into a trilogy they can do execution
or song eventually but that's such a big
story that you kind of have to work up
to it and whatever x-force ends up being
it'll be more of a cable story than a
Deadpool story it'll be like a cable
story with a lot of Deadpool in it let
me know in the comments though let's
assume for the sake of this video the
x-force gets a new trilogy I mean it
might take them a while to get all those
three movies out what story do you want
them to do that will cross over those
three movies each movie kind of has to
be its own self-contained story but
beyond that think about the macro story
that would cross all three of those
movies which i think is strife
executioner song i think that's a very
safe bet because it also kind of ties in
with the apocalypse stuff but only
tangentially it's mostly a story about
cable trying to kill his clone who just
happens to be working for apocalypse so
what's gonna happen next is there's some
more Marvel stuff happening this weekend
so I'm Captain America Civil Wars some
Avengers stuff be sure to subscribe to
get everything you guys have been
leaving some awesome Deadpool
suggestions for bonus videos so I'll pry
start doing those next week because a
couple
things are on break while you wait for
all that stuff to post and the Marvel
stuff this weekend you can click here
for all my Deadpool videos and you can
click here to learn all about Ben
Affleck changing the Batman V Superman
script thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you